vraiment c'est extrêmement extrêmement
prometteurs comme approche et c'est ce
qu'ont un bio gêne en quelque sorte
et donc on enchante rap décomposer
immunothérapeutique des cellules
immunitaires anticancer d'autres sortes
de composer nous amener directement la
semaine là plusieurs étapes qui sont
relativement simples chimiquement
mais quand même plusieurs étapes donc la
première c'est de nous on utilise en
fait de chitosane qui est issu de la
chitine qui provient de la carapace de
crustacés dont qui doit être purifiée
donc ça devienne poudre de clausade qui
ensuite est mélangé à pâques et demi en
solutions acides et ensuite qui mélangée
avec un agent génie fillon qui également
en solution donc c'était un peu ça
l'heure le mystère de la recette c'est
le bon choix de ses agents jeu
gélifiants et leur bon ratio entre eux
et ensuite on m'a donc fait tout
simplement mélanger ces deux agents et
lorsqu'ils seront mélangés ils vont
rester liquide à solution à température
pièce mais ensuite ils vont ce génie
fier à 37 degrés et donc c'est tout là
la beauté de la chose ce sont vraiment
des gels qu'on appelle thermosensibles
qui vont au début rester liquide à
température ambiante mais qui vont
pouvoir durcir solidifier in vivo les
gros de les gros défi pour ce vieux gel
c'est qu'il soit injectable mais qui
ensuite ils forment une matrice solide
mais pour euse pour servir de réservoir
justement pour ces cellules énorme
avantage ce biogen là c'est que c'est
pas n'importe quel bio gel ce à dire que
les bio gels peuvent être toxiques pour
les cellules qu'on va en capsules hier
et ce qui est fantastique ce qu'on a
démontré en fait dans nos travaux
récents c'est que non seulement les
cellules vont rester dans le gène et
vont elles vont elles vont être
heureuses et pendant deux semaines trois
semaines les lèvres les lymphocytes t
les cellules immunitaires convent
encapsulé dans le bios jeunes vont
continuer à proliférer vin très heureuse
et même elles vont sortir du jer le
montrent et elles sont capables de
sortir du gel et d'aller twin tu m'as
qui à côte ils sont le modéliser une vie
trop donc ça fonctionne à savoir que le
bio gel non seulement permet
d'encapsuler des cellules et des
composés mes cellules restent très
heureux c'est pas toxique et les
cellules peuvent même continuer à
fonctionner et à sortir du jeu